from her breakout season at the age of
17 to her fifth Grand Slam title 10
years later Maria Sharapova was one of
the few true superstars on the women's
circuit Sharapova shown as a youngster
despite the emerging dominance of Serena
Williams whom she beat in the 2004
Wimbledon final their ensuing rivalry
meaning that the American and her sister
Venus had some genuine competition for
their Hall of titles born in Soviet era
Russia but crafting her talent in
Florida her worldwide appeal sparked
Maria mania among fans and the media but
after becoming one of the select group
of players to clinch a career slam of
all four major titles her tilt at a
second Australian Open crown in 2016
ended in scandal
Sharapova testing positive for meldonium
that had been included on the WTA's
banned list at the start of that year I
know that with this I I faced
consequences and I I don't want to end
my career this way and I really hope
that I will be given another chance to
play this game she did gets another
chance but only after a 15-month ban saw
her cast out from her place in
Tennessee's golden generation just shy
of three years on it's proved impossible
to reclaim former glories and reputation
but eleven years straight as Forbes
highest paid female athlete means she
goes out with career earnings of 325
million dollars as injuries finally take
their toll on a player who will hope her
early brilliance is remembered more than
her later mistakes maurice al-jazeera